welcome to the Daily climate show coming
up
so Kia storm a pleasure is to set up a
publicly owned green Energy company
within a year if he's elected
hurricane Ian makes landfall in Cuba
with Winds of 125 miles per hour
and how the public can make their
concerns about climate known to party
leaders
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world and the race to
find potential solutions to The Climate
crisis but today we start with news that
Sakia starma has promised labor would
create a publicly owned green energy
firm if he becomes prime minister at his
keynote speech in Liverpool today the
labor leader announced he'll make a new
clean generation company that will use
the power of Britain's Sun wind and
waves called Great British energy Sakia
claims his party would tackle the
climate emergency head on to benefit
British people
a new company that takes advantage of
the opportunities in clean British power
and because it is right for jobs
because it is right for growth because
it's a right for energy independence
from tyrants like Putin then yes
conference Great British energy will be
publicly owned
our chief political correspondent John
Craig joins me now live from Liverpool
uh John so a clear alignment with a
green future from labor
thank you
yes and uh popular policy nationalizing
if you like the whole of British energy
a one big new company Boris Johnson when
he was prime minister did talk about a
new National Grid uh uh a nationalized
National Grid at some point that's never
happened but it is of course reversing
the privatization of energy by the
conservatives in the 80s and 90s for
example in electricity we used to have
the central electricity generating board
which is a nationalized industry and the
area boards which supplied it
um electricity and of course Regional
gas cutter boards as well so but miss
what sakir is talking about is one big
company a bit like EDF electricity de
France in France and and prior to that
standing ovation which you saw there one
of uh 10 throughout the 50-minute speech
Sakia was talking about what's happening
at the moment he said the largest
onshore wind farm in Wales who owns it
Sweden he said energy bills in Swansea
are paying for schools and hospitals in
Stockholm the Chinese Communist party
has a stake in our nuclear industry well
he's talking about the size well project
there uh sorry the Hinckley project are
down in Somerset there which a deal
signed by George Osborne and he was
Chancellor the exchequer and he said
five million people in Britain pay their
bills to an energy company owned by
France that's EDF electricity de France
which is part nationalized I think I'm
right in saying
um so he's talking about uh Great
British energy within the first year of
a labor government he said a new company
that takes advantage of the
opportunities in clean British power and
he said it was right for jobs and growth
okay John always great to talk to you
thank you for that update John Craig
there now hurricane Ian has made
landfall in Cuba with top wind speeds of
125 miles per hour and it's only going
to get stronger as it makes its way
towards Florida now the National
Hurricane Center says there is a risk of
flash flooding strong winds Storm surges
of up to 10 feet tall and possible
isolated tornadoes along Florida's Gulf
coasts and as the world gets warmer due
to climate change hurricanes are
becoming more intense and that's all
because as the Earth's surface
temperature rises more liquid a wrap
evaporates from the ocean and this
evaporation adds moisture to the air and
the increased moisture in the air leads
to more intense rainfall therefore as
the air continues to warm due to climate
change hurricanes can hold more water
vapor producing more intense rainfall
rates well joining me now now is
Professor Rafe Toomey from The Faculty
of national Sciences at the Grantham
Institute for climate change thanks so
much for joining us Rafe first of all
can you just tell us the impact climate
change has had on hurricanes and how
they work
thank you yeah my name's Ralph
um
the way they work is really through what
we call a positive feedback so the
Cyclones are actually very good at
extracting heat energy out of the ocean
and that then converts to rain and that
actually strengthens the hurricane and
the wind goes up and you have more
stronger Cyclone stronger wind more
evaporation and on it goes so that's how
they can intensify very rapidly as this
one is at the moment so if you change
the basic condition in order in other
words the ocean temperature
then you starting off from a much better
position of evaporating yet more water
vapor and then the feedback comes
becomes all together more stronger
overall and also speeds up more quickly
so we are concerned that as the ocean
warms uh Cyclones become stronger and
wetter
and there's no way of course of stopping
hurricanes but what do you think in your
research are the best options for
mitigation
so one of the big things we've we've
already achieved as a you know as a
group a collective humans through
computers and satellite observations we
can now forecast these events really
quite well so now we're talking about
Florida what might happen on Thursday
well if you think about before the
satellite era and the computers there
would have been hundreds of thousands of
people at risk of dying frankly without
this so we've got better forecasts
that's great we need to build better we
need to evacuate people better
and then we also need to reduce the main
cause of anomalous sea surface
temperatures the anomalous warming
that's probably happening at the moment
in the in the Gulf of Mexico and that
would be reducing greenhouse gas
emissions okay you're off to me thank
you very much for joining us on the
climate show today
okay in other climate news heat pumps it
could be well they could become cheaper
and easier to install in the future as
the government has awarded more than 15
million pounds in funding for Innovation
projects and ministers have set up a
target of 600 000 pumps to be installed
in a year by 2028 as they bid to
accelerate the rollout so households
move away from using costly fossil fuels
but also today farmers in Wales could be
paid to help protect nature and fight
climate change under new reforms to
agriculture so the Welsh government said
its long-awaited agriculture Bill marked
a historic moment now the bill paves the
way for Welsh ministers to set up and
operate a brand new subsidy scheme for
Farmers with a much Greener Focus there
well images of updated banknotes
featuring a portrait of the king will be
revealed by the bank of England by the
end of this year so coins and banknotes
featuring King Charles III and Queen
Elizabeth II will co-circulate in line
with guidance from the Royal household
to minimize the environmental and
financial impact of the change of
Monarch so currency
featuring The Queen will be replaced
over time as coins and notes become
walled or damaged
now here's a question for you would
sending a letter to the Prime Minister
Liz truss and the leader of the
opposition sakistama every day make you
feel any different about climate change
well the group Climate Coalition is
urging people to write to our leaders to
remind them about the level of public
concern and they're they're also asking
people to pen letters to loved ones
telling them how they'd like the planet
to be in the future so when it comes to
how we're all feeling about the future
of the planet how anxious are we whilst
guys sabachoudry joins us now you've got
all the numbers let's talk us through
how anxious people are feeling good
afternoon Leo well this is clearly
something that is worrying a lot of
people seven in ten individuals that
were surveyed by the climate change
Coalition are saying that they are
seriously concerned about the impact
that climate change is going to have on
the future of our planet but according
to the organization Greenpeace they're
saying that we should really not be
surprised by this given the summer that
we've just seen so on their website they
say say you're really not imagining it
there really were a lot of climate
disasters this summer and then they go
on to cite the floods in Pakistan the
record Heat and the wildfires that we
saw here in the UK and also the droughts
across Europe the worst droughts that
we've seen in the past 500 years and
they're saying for this reason that this
is why it's been resonating with a lot
of people exactly because it's been so
close to home a lot of it now uh 45
of parents This research from the
climate change Coalition has found
are really worried about the future of
their children and and they're saying
that so much more than things like
health and other uh things including
money and job worries now this is a huge
concern for parents but not just parents
but the general population the results
uh have found in it's wise you touched
on earlier climate change Coalition I've
kick-started a new campaign the letters
to tomorrow exactly and what this is
encouraging people to do a bit like a
time capsule is to write a letter to
their future loved ones basically
illustrating what they would like the
future to look like if there are leaders
were to act now and uh they're also
going to be writing letters to prime
minister Liz truss and to leader of the
opposition sir kiss Dharma encouraging
them to act now they're saying if this
matters to the people it should really
matter to you now we it is of course the
labor Party Conference we're seeing that
is happening up in Liverpool and circus
Dharma has spoken about uh how he hopes
to reduce energy bills and his green
plan for that prime minister has also
spoken about her green plan but really
what these stats show us Leah is that
it's action and not just words that
people want absolutely Saba thank thank
you very much for going through those
numbers for us well that's all for now
on the climate show we'll be back
tomorrow thank you very much for
watching but for now we'll hand back to
Sarah Jane